[Music]
i i think that here's what's happening
and i mean i think that there's some
glimmer of hope because we've been
seeing a lot of normies that normally
even aren't political starting to turn
and go like this is getting crazy like
yeah now it's affecting my life now it's
affecting my life like it's one thing
when you know it's and we said it on the
show and it's not just because you're on
like you know to suck up to you but this
is true we said it when you were banned
from everything we're like all these
people are cheating i'm like it's going
to start with him and then you know
what's going to happen it's going to be
you and now they're banning jordan
peterson off of twitter everybody off of
twitter screaming about him like you
didn't care when it when it wasn't you
and that brings me to this question the
one thing i never thought i would hear
in 2022 is somebody on fox news not only
talk about you but praise you tucker has
been mentioning you quite a bit lately
and i was running what you thought about
that yeah
well if i'm friends with tucker i'll
leave it at that
um you know we hang out and stuff and um
he's a populist he's a smart guy he's
really smart and i like him uh and uh
you know i'm banned on fox and of course
he tried to have me on and they said we
don't care he he actually took a lot
less money to do whatever he wants
and we went and said well my contract
says i can do whatever i want they said
well you don't care what your contract
says you ain't have any money so that's
kind of what that is but but but
it's kind of cooler to be banned and and
be the guy in the phantom zone but you
know you know getting back to where we
are politically and where the world is
right now
it's the system that did all this it's
the system that screwed us over and the
establishment that's hated so they could
ban you ban me ban joe rogan tomorrow
it's not going to matter because
everyone knows they're being lied to we
don't want the great reset we don't want
klaus schwab flying around a private jet
with uh bill gates and and prince
charles while we go bankrupt and we're
just not buying it so they're trying to
run an agenda of feudalism
in the 21st century and it may have
worked 500 years ago but the renaissance
said record skip car wreck sound no
and so they're trying to run a play they
ran before and it ain't going to work
what it's going to cause is a big war
and uh maybe the end of the world so we
are in very very exciting times right
now
yeah we are looking exciting is a good
addre
we are really at that boiling point
right where it's that's it like
something something massive is going to
have to happen because
never we've never been this divided i've
never seen people this completely
divided the government is now you know
again something else that everyone used
to be like oh alex jones thinks there's
going to be fema camps i'm like well
yeah they literally they're literally
australia was doing there have been
again there's been fema camps before
and and now they're they're they're
building them in in in the us
they're building them in the uk they're
building them in
canada yeah i mean look hey folks keep
laughing alex jones you're living what i
told you because people go
it's jones one of this is my biggest
frustration
because not just the establishment
attacking me or the democrats attacking
me
if you go to twitter or facebook
anywhere i get it every day it's he
knows all this because he's one of them
uh no
you can go reads abigail brzezinski's
books you can go read klaus swaps books
you can go watch the davos group they're
on they're saying you'll own nothing
you'll have nothing you'll like it
you're going to eat bugs you're going to
drink sewage these are quotes
and i'm going this is horrible
these people are horrible
and they're going to do this and they
had like operation lockstep and all
these drills that were down to the day
what they would do and how they would do
it i started watching how everything
they said in the document was day to day
the plan because they had to do a drill
because if they announce their plan they
go to jail but if it's a drill
which is really a battle plan
like like imagine you have a script the
cops pull you over and you're driving
erratically and there's some blood on
the windshield whatever and they found a
dead body in the trunk a little kid
i don't know where that little kid came
from they get it and they go what's this
they opened up a diary where you say i
kidnapped little jenny from her backyard
and took her and raped her for two weeks
then i killed her you you get the you
get the electric chair you get the
lethal injection but if it was
my script how i kidnapped jenny and
raped her and killed her oh it's a
script for a movie it doesn't matter
little jenny's in the back of the car
doesn't matter her blood's all over the
place and there's there's there's
there's scrapes from her fingernails in
your chest as long as you say oh
that was just a movie so they do drills
and they do these war games as their
battle plan and then they launch it
that's what you need to look into
operation northwoods
um operation lockstep
spars
2025-2028 folks these aren't just things
i'm saying look them up and then you'll
be in my mind when you reach spars 20 25
2028 it's 2000 2023 it's like virus
comes out of china attacks the repertory
system here's the tweets we put out when
it happens then we have then we have
them wear mass to create fear it says
this and then we have lockdowns and then
and then a year later we admit the
vaccine doesn't work and then we do this
then it collapses society and no one
believes in it and the
the tweets hundreds of them
are the exact tweets they put out later
they wrote this in in 2018
and then in 2000 it's the exact tweets
except they changed the acronyms so you
move the letters and it's the same
headline
so criminals love to brag they literally
wrote a battle plan spars 2025 2028 that
is the operative operation for what
they're doing some people go hell does
jones know what's coming next these
freaking psychos have a playbook